the department of justice announced in
the metro police department needed to
change
after an extensive review the doj wrote
in this report
the shooting of unarmed suspects remains
a concern
for example between 2007 and 2011 there
were 10
officer-involved shootings that involved
unarmed suspects
seven were black i think it's safe to
say they were not in keeping
with best practices the department
implemented multiple changes
in 2019 metro reports out of 16
shootings by police
15 of the subjects were armed there is
an
emphasis on de-escalation techniques
in this report analyzing a five-year
period through
2019 the department provides use of
force data
while also acknowledging lessons are
still being learned
it notes four critical incidents in 2019
in which the coroner determined officers
actions
may have contributed to the subject's
cause of death
[Applause]
[Music]
the clark county coroner's office ruled
byron williams death a homicide because
the prone restraint officers placed him
in was a factor
in addition to meth in his system and
health issues
he ran from police after they tried
stopping him for not having a bicycle
light
once they had him in custody williams
told officers he couldn't breathe at
least 24
times multiple officers deactivated
their body cameras at the scene
he deserves justice like what they did
to him was not
was not right it was not fair it was
inhumane the use of force review board
comprised of both commissioned officers
and four citizens
determined officers should have
immediately rolled williams on his side
after he was handcuffed and their
medical response violated training and
policy
metro took action notifying all officers
to place suspects on their side or sit
them up
so they are not kept in a position like
williams was
and to get medical attention immediately
in a situation like this
the department also updated policy
officers must keep their body cameras on
while at a scene
donovan britt is a citizen volunteer on
the review board we kind of see
these events and we understand what they
should be doing and something that's
outside of the norm we have
we can focus in on and go why is that
the case the board also makes
recommendations on
officer discipline according to the
department out of 31 cases reviewed in
14 officers were disciplined none were
fired and one resigned
captain fred haas works in internal
affairs if there are bad cops out there
i don't want them standing next to me
out there in the community
and throughout the community in 2020
there were black lives matter protests
and calls for police reform while metro
is more advanced than many departments
incidents like william's death
demonstrate there are still
serious flaws that need to be fixed
vanessa murphy 8 news now